We Begin here this morning with the
sudden death of Grant Wall a CBS Sports
contributor and the leading soccer
writer in the U.S wall was covering the
Argentina Netherlands quarterfinal at
the World Cup in Qatar on Friday when he
collapsed Roxanna seberia is in our
London Bureau with the latest Roxanna
good morning
good morning Jeff Grant Wall was a
well-loved highly respected Sports
journalist and he was kind those close
to the situation say he may have
suffered a heart attack or a pulmonary
event though the exact cause of his
death is not yet known for those of us
who recently spent time with him at the
World Cup his death is a shock
the World Cup just feels like you're at
the center of the universe Grant Wall
was covering his 13th World Cup the
quarterfinal between the Netherlands and
Argentina when he collapsed last night
in the Press Box at a stadium in Qatar
his agent tells CBS News paramedics
tried to revive wall then took him to a
nearby hospital on Tuesday the 48 year
old journalist had written he was on
antibiotics for bronchitis an illness
that has spread widely at the World Cup
born in Mission Kansas wall graduated
from Princeton University and went on to
become one of the most renowned soccer
journalists and authors in the U.S in
his popular newsletter he wrote about
the conditions of Migrant workers
building soccer stadiums in Qatar and
getting briefly detained for wearing a
rainbow t-shirt there in support of
lgbtq rights as a CBS Sports contributor
his passion for soccer was clear we're
still a growing Soccer Country in the
United States with I would say millions
of more soccer fans to be created in a
statement U.S soccer said wall played a
major role in helping to drive interest
in and respect for our beautiful game
adding we are devastated that he and His
Brilliant writing will no longer be with
us Basketball Star LeBron James whom
wall had featured in a Sports
Illustrated cover two decades ago also
paid tribute
I'm very fond of Grant and uh
you know having that um
that cover shoot you know me being a
teenager and him covering that it was um
it was a pretty cool thing
wall leaves behind his wife Dr Celine
gowender a CBS News contributor she
tweeted last night she's in complete
shock Dana
all right Roxanna thank you very much
and we've been talking about it all
morning guys it is a shock
I was amazed or maybe not amazed it
spoke volumes about what you saw on
social media everybody from an intern
who worked with him to those who worked
alongside of him for years talking about
what a wonderful guy he was I spent time
with Grant I know you have two I've
interviewed him if you were going to
talk to an American journalist about
soccer it was him if you want to talk to
American period about soccer it was it
was Grant he was he loved the sports so
much
and he was a good man yeah yeah he was a
good man he made a lot of people love
soccer too right right men and women's
soccer and certainly our thoughts are
with uh Dr Gander absolutely and his
family this morning it's a shock